MARK MIRCHANDANI: One of
the greatest advantages
of the cloud is
how easy it can be
to scale your usage up or down.
However, if you're working with
a predictable compute workload,
you can save some money with
committed use discounts.
On this episode of
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll talk about what
committed use discounts are
and how you can maximize
your usage of them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Committed Use Discounts,
or CUDs for short,
are basically
contracts saying you'll
commit to a certain amount
of Compute Engine resource
for a one or three-year period.
In exchange for your
commitment, you'll
get a significant price
discount, even as high as 70%,
in some cases.
You can make these commitments
on typical compute resources
such as vCPUs and memory, but
also on GPUs and local SSDs.
It's worth noting that
committed use discounts aren't
the same thing as sustained
use discounts, which
are separate discounts
that can't be combined
with committed use discounts.
There's a link below with
more information on those.
Let's look a bit more on
how to set up commitments.
And then explore the committed
use discount analysis
report, which allows you to
visualize your commitments.
This report is meant to help
you answer questions like,
how much of my eligible
Compute Engine usage
is covered by my commitments?
How much are my commitments
actually saving me?
And am I fully utilizing
my existing commitments?
To start, you can purchase
commitments in the Google Cloud
Console by using the
top left navigation
and clicking on Committed Use
Discounts under Compute Engine.
From here, click on
Purchase Commitment
to enter the specifics,
such as the time frame
and which resource
you want to purchase.
Each commitment is purchased for
a specific project and region.
Commitments for
vCPUs and memories
are applied
simultaneously, but you
can have separate commitments
for GPUs and local SSDs.
You'll also get
an estimated cost
to let you see how much
you'll pay each month
and how much the
commitment would save you.
If you run into issues
purchasing a commitment,
you may need to make sure
that you have a quota for it.
There's also a link below with
more information for that.
Once you've made the
commitment, you'll
start to pay for that
commitment over its lifetime
with each billing
cycle, even if you don't
have any resources active.
In this example, a certain
amount of vCPUs and RAM
have been used by a
Compute Engine instance.
The amount that's
covered by a commitment
will be credited back and
the lower commitment rate
will be applied for that usage.
However, if you've got lots
of resources and commitments,
it can be confusing to see
exactly what you're spending
and which commitments
you have active,
especially since commitments
don't auto renew.
That's where the committed
use discount analysis
report comes in.
It helps you visualize
all of your commitments
alongside your
compute resources.
Using the Google
Cloud Console, choose
a billing account and click
on the Commitments option
to get to the report.
You'll need to be
a billing account
administrator or a
billing account viewer
to see this report.
Unlike billing
reports, you won't
be able to get
access to this report
just by being a project
owner, though you will
be able to filter by project.
Let's step through
the different areas
to see how the report works.
The resources are
split up by type.
So you can see vCPU, RAM,
SSD, and each type of GPU
separately with your usage
and the relevant commitments.
You can toggle between them
by clicking the tabs here,
but we'll start with vCPUs.
Above the graph, you
can see a quick summary
of your commitments.
The left side lets you see if
you're looking at all regions
or if you're only looking
at a specific region, which
I'll show you how to
do in just a second.
The middle shows
the current number
of active commitments,
which may take
a day or two to update when a
new commitment is purchased.
The right side shows you the
utilization of your commitments
by comparing the amount of
eligible usage being covered
by your commitments to the
total number of commitments
that you have.
You can also hover
over the question mark
for the specific
resource counts.
The stacked bar chart
itself shows you
the resource uses for
each day, the amount that
was covered by a
commitment, and a line that
shows you the current
quantity of commitments.
You can hover over each
column to see the exact usage
numbers for every day.
There's also a summary
table below the chart.
Let's take a look at a
specific subset of days.
Here you can see the usage
narrowed down to a few days.
On the first day,
all commitments
were fully utilized.
And there were additional
eligible resource usage
on top of your
purchase commitments.
If you often see resource
usage above your additional
commitments, it may
make sense to purchase
additional commitments to cover
that usage and save some money.
However, you can also see
that on the next few days,
the commitments haven't changed,
but the amount used has.
Since this is the
cloud, it makes sense
that resource usage
can fluctuate.
But how can we find out
why these resources weren't
covered?
Let's drill down
using the filters.
You can also change
the time ranges here,
if you want to see more dates.
We'll change the view to Region
and see the specifics split up
by each region.
This is the US
Central One region,
but the graph is still showing
the same usage pattern.
Remember that
committed use discounts
are specific to a
project and a region.
So let's use the filters to
select a specific project.
With this filter, we can
see that less vCPUs were
used for a few days
in this project, which
led to the commitment
being underutilized.
Understanding more details
about commitment utilization
can give you a much
better idea of how to plan
for future usage of resources.
Or even where you
may want to purchase
additional commitments.
As you've seen, committed
to use discounts
can save you money on your
Compute Engine resources,
especially if you have a
lot of consistent usage.
It's also important to use the
committed use discount analysis
report to see how your existing
commitments are sizing up
and if it makes
sense to purchase
additional commitments.
Check out the links
for more information
and try out the report for
yourself in the GCP console.
[MUSIC PLAYING]